In the last video,
we touched a bit
on the idea of final
goods and services.
And we talked about
the situation in which
in the given period that
we're calculating GDP.
So this might be
in a given year.
If we're essentially
starting from scratch
and we put in the labor,
the land, we get the cotton.
The market value of that
is $10, that raw cotton.
And then we're able to turn
that into thread with a market
value of $20 and we keep going.
And we keep on going and
going all the way until we
get the finished product of
jeans, which has a market
value of $50, we saw
in the last video
that the contribution
to GDP will just
be this final product.
It will just be the
$50 worth of jeans.
And we know its value
based on its market value,
what people are
willing to pay for it.
We would not count all of
these intermediary goods.
But that probably raised
the question in your head.
What if all of this does
not happen in a given year?
What if the period
ends, what if the year
were to end right over here?
So we're thinking
about GDP in a year,
but we could think about GDP
in a quarter or whatever.
What if the period under
question ends over here?
So this is period one.
Let's call this period one.
And then this is going
to be period two.
So in period one,
we get to the point
that we have a market
value $20 worth of threat.
And then period two, we get
all the way to the jeans.
So this is period two over here.
So this might be one year.
And then this might be
the year after that.
What would happen
is in period one,
we would look at this good,
this intermediary good that's
sitting in someone's inventory
someplace that's getting ready
to be used to get
more finished, we
would say this is the
contribution to GDP.
And it would be
considered an investment
because it's going to
be used in the future
to produce other things.
So in period one, the
contribution will be $20.
And then in period
two, the contribution
won't be just the $50.
So we do get to a point that
the jeans are worth $50.
But so that we haven't
double counted the same $20
in both period one
and period two,
we'll subtract out what
our starting point was.
Or essentially,
we'll subtract out
the contribution, the
intermediary products that
were already counted
in previous periods.
Or you could say,
we'll subtract out
the market value of the
inputs at the beginning
of that period.
So you'd say, $50 minus the $20.
And so you would get
a contribution to GDP
by taking this $20
intermediary good
and turning it into
a $50 final good,
the contribution to GDP in
period two would be $30.